- [Interviewer] All right, Whisper.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] Whisper,
where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Whisper] Flint, Michigan.
- Flint, Michigan.
- Yeah, Flint and Detroit.
- [Interviewer] And Detroit, me too.
- [Whisper] (chuckling) Mainly Flint.
- [Interviewer] And how was your family?
You grew up with both of your parents?
- Yeah.
My dad was a good dude.
I mean, he's a good dude.
He was real family-oriented.
My mother, on the other hand, was,
I don't even know what to call her.
She hated her kids, she really did.
There was four of us altogether,
and me and my brothers,
she hated for some reason.
She was just vicious to us.
And when, my dad went to prison,
'cause they were both junkies.
But, my dad went to prison
and a couple weeks before
my 13th birthday, my mom
started being nice to me,
out of nowhere.
And got me strung out using with her.
And didn't I know, she
only did that because
she wanted to sell me to men.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- At 12.
- [Interviewer] 12.
- I lost my virginity to
this dude named Danny Door.
He was a sexual predator.
I didn't find out this 'til later.
But when I had my first date with him
when I lost my virginity,
I remember, he's an old man,
he was like, 60-something.
But, it hurt and he was really rough
and he was like, "does it hurt?"
And he was smiling like
yeah, like it was funny.
And I got paid 500 for it,
but he gave the money to my mother.
So when I came out the bedroom
after I got out the shower,
she's gone.
And then he trips out, talking about,
"oh, you can't be in here.
"You're underage, you can't be
in here without your mother.
"I'll get in trouble."
So of course, I get put out
in the middle of winter,
the buses aren't running,
and I had to walk home.
And I'm already strung out at this point.
So I go home, my mother's
nowhere to be found.
And then two days later, she
comes home with this dude
that was covered in hair.
I mean, he was so gross,
they called him Tiny,
but he was like, 400 pounds.
She said if I wanted to get well,
I would do this date with him.
And I was like, "well,
let me get well first."
She said, "no, do the date
and then you get well."
I didn't know how to hit myself,
so I had to depend on her a lot.
And then, of course, she
would want a fix first,
and then nod out trying to hit me.
It was just all bad with her.
But that was the only
time she was nice to me,
is when I was doing dates for her.
Other than that, she
basically hated us and didn't
make no apologies about doing it.
When I turned 15, my dad got out of prison
and found me in a dope
house with my mother.
He didn't even recognize me.
I had all this makeup on,
I was, well, yeah, 15.
Had all this makeup on, he
didn't even recognize me.
He just snatched my mother up,
'cause my grandmother told him,
"yeah, Linda has Chrissy on
Dort Highway selling pussy
"and strung out on heroin."
And I guess he damn
near choked on his fork,
he was like, "what?"
And she said, "yeah, you heard me."
So he left and he went looking for us.
And that's where he found
us, was the dope house.
And he was in such a rage with my mother,
he beat the shit out of her
in the middle of the street.
She ended up getting the
whole side of her face rewired
and her arm was broke in four places.
But when I tried to stop him,
he didn't even recognize me.
Then he finally realized who I was,
and kinda started crying and was like,
kept telling me he was sorry,
to give him another chance to be my dad.
So, I told him yeah. (chuckling)
Little did I know, I'd go
home and was forced to kick.
I was so mad at him then.
It was like, why are you
gonna let me be sick?
He was like, "'cause I
can't put poison in you."
So I stayed with him for like, two years,
and then, almost three, and
I came out to California.
'Cause my best friend/girlfriend
had a brother who had a
escort service out here
in the Yellow Pages.
So of course, I came out here.
I met a lot of people.
One of my regulars was (censored).
- [Interviewer] I don't know
if we should name names.
- Oh. (laughing)
Okay.
- I'll leave that out.
- Well, okay, delete that out.
But he was one of my regulars.
I mean, I've met a lot of people.
I did that for a few years.
Course, I relapsed when I came out here.
After I left the agency
because he packed up
and moved back to Michigan,
of course, I'm strung out again.
No family--
- Your dad moved back
to Michigan?
- No, I moved from Michigan.
My girlfriend's brother
who had the escort agency
moved back to Michigan.
- Oh, I see, okay.
- So it's like, now I
have nobody out here.
I'm by myself, I'm strung
out again, and what do I do?
I started putting ads in the LA Express.
Somebody showed me how to do that.
And I was working the
streets in Hollywood.
Course, that was, not like
I wasn't familiar with it.
My mother showed me how to
work the streets back home.
This was just easier to me, I thought.
I mean, I've had a lot
of bad situations happen.
You go park up on the hills or something,
and then you realize there's another dude
laying down in the backseat.
And then the guy tells you
to give him his money back.
I've had guns pulled on me.
I mean, what haven't I had happen?
And they say whatever don't
kill you makes you stronger.
Then I went to prison, I've
been to prison four times.
- [Interviewer] Prison for what?
Drugs?
- Drugs.
Possession of heroin.
Now, it's a misdemeanor, you
get a ticket and get let go.
But I did my first prison trip for drugs.
I've seen a lot of shit in prison, dude.
That's a whole 'nother world.
People think it's
nothing, it is something.
The COs are crooked.
Inmates, of course they're crooked.
But it's like, I don't
know how to explain it.
I guess if you kiss a lot of
ass, you get cool with the COs
and your life's a lot easier.
And if you get in with some lifers,
then you're kinda protected.
You don't have to worry
about really nothing,
just don't get in the dope game.
Or mess with anybody's
girlfriend. (laughing)
That's the only thing
that really causes you
any problem in prison.
Just mind your business, I guess.
Stay to yourself.
Stay to our own business.
And it's easy.
Make it to your parole
date, if you have one.
A lot of girls up there,
they don't have one.
I met this girl named
Silly, she had double life.
She was 19 years old, left
a one-year-old baby at home.
And now, she runs most
of the dope in the pen
(chuckling) up there, she's cool, though.
- [Interviewer] And how long have you been
down here on Skid Row?
- Skid Row, when I first moved out here,
I stayed in the Valley.
Course, I was working
for an escort service.
I've been down on Skid Row since I was 21.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 43.
I could show you some
pictures that would just
blow you away, you'd be
like, "no, this is not you.
"You're kidding me."
Yeah.
Even just a few years back.
I had an apartment for a while.
I was off the streets, and it's like,
I've been on the streets for two years
since I lost my Explorer.
No, my Expedition, it was an Expedition.
So then I lost my truck,
it's been so hard.
I lost my apartment and my truck.
And I've been out here for
two, almost three years,
and you can see the difference.
I was looking at my picture, I was like,
"goddamn, I look good."
And it was only three years ago.
Damn, is it that rough when you get older?
It wears on you, I guess a lot more,
'cause when you're young,
you're more resilient.
You're able to bounce back better.
- [Interviewer] It's
a tough life out here.
- Tough ain't the word, dude.
I've seen some shit.
You're talking about,
dude digging holes and
putting body parts places,
and it's like, "no, cool."
They're like, "go get the thick plastic,"
and I'm like, do I get
it, or do I just leave,
or am I gonna be put in the plastic too,
'cause if you trip out and get scared
and they think you're scared,
they think you're gonna tell.
So you might end up in
that plastic with them.
So what do you do, act
like everything's cool
and you just do what they say.
That's some fucking way out shit.
- [Interviewer] And what
is your drug now, heroin?
- [Whisper] Yeah heroin, I
smoke crack, too, but heroin.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money now?
- [Whisper] Me, I hustle, I sell dope.
- [Interviewer] Do you still date guys?
- [Whisper] No.
I haven't dated, thank god, in like,
two, almost three years.
That's a blessing.
My homeboy from A-team
showed me that I had another
skill, selling drugs.
I didn't know I could sell
'em, 'cause I use 'em.
But I know everybody that gets high.
So it's easy for me to
sell, 'cause a lot of 'em
wanna just kick it with me.
So I sell a lot, I'm
good at selling drugs.
I didn't know that was a skill of mine.
But I was the only one working
for him for a long time,
and I made homeboy a lot of money, dude.
I mean, I owe him 6,900 right now.
But I was pregnant and didn't know it.
I was like, seven months pregnant,
didn't know it, found out.
A week later, I almost
died in the parking lot
because I'm RH negative.
I'm supposed to have a
shot to carry to full-term,
and my body reacts to it like an infection
and tries to abort.
For some reason, she had
kicked her placenta to pieces.
She survived.
Doctor don't know how, but she survived.
He said he's seen the placenta, or the sac
with a tear in it, he's seen
it detached from the uterus,
but he has never seen it in chunks.
And I guess it, within hours,
started to spoil immediately,
which made me septic.
It was poisoning me.
And I don't know how she
survived all of that.
She did, though.
And that's why I passed
out in the parking lot,
and they called the ambulance.
And then, I woke up two days later
with eyelids this thick,
swollen off my face.
And talking about I was septic, poisoned.
They don't know if I'm
taking to the antibiotics,
but it looked good, and
that my baby was in the
neonatal intensive care unit,
fully developed, seven months.
So that was a blessing.
But of course, she was full of drugs.
I didn't know I was pregnant.
I had my first son at 34, Jalon.
When I found out I was
pregnant with him, I got clean.
I got on methadone, did
what I was supposed to do,
brought him home.
The only thing was, I was absconding
and I had a pro warrant.
I wasn't doing my parole right.
But I didn't get busted 'til
he was like, a year old.
And they bust me and take my son from me.
And you have like, six months
to do your ramification.
Well anyways, I lose my
son while I was in prison.
That was my first love.
- [Interviewer] How many kids do you have?
- Two.
Yeah.
I waited a long time for him.
He's gonna be 10.
- [Interviewer] Who is he with?
- I don't know.
Somewhere out here.
(sniffling)
And then, I had my daughter full of drugs.
So I didn't even try to fight for her.
I was all fucked up in the head,
and it started fucking up with my sacks.
I would sit outside the hospital and just
smoke and smoke and shoot dope.
My homeboy used to give me
two $800 sacks at a time.
So I'd fuck up like, four times,
and that's 6,900, dude.
I'm like, wow, but that's
nothing but a drop in the bucket
compared to what I've made you.
I used to re-up like, eight times a day.
That's 1,600, eight times
a day, you do the math.
And you're tripping over 6,900?
Whatever.
That's why he's having
such a hard time now.
None of his people (chuckling)
can make money like I do.
He even says it to this day
like, "yeah, that was my ace.
"Whisper was my ace, but she fucked up."
Yeah, I fucked up.
My bad.
I guess it would be
different if I was Victoria
sucking his dick. (chuckling)
'Cause she owes him more than I do,
and she's still working for him.
But I don't suck his dick. (chuckling)
I guess that makes a difference.
- [Interviewer] And
what do you have planned
for your future, do
you have any plans of--
- Me, I wanna get clean, but
they all say that, right?
(laughing)
- Everybody says that.
- Everybody says it, but
bullshit to the side,
I'm happy when I'm high.
I don't feel nothing
when I'm getting high.
I'm enjoying myself, I
guess that's because of
all I've ever known, really.
I've never been normal.
Halfway normal when I
was pregnant with my son.
I got my first apartment myself.
I was doing everything.
Learned how to (chuckling)
get Ralph's for diapers,
you know the $50 box of diapers?
I would weigh 'em as banana weight,
and I would buy the wipes for $4.
So the $50 box of diapers,
I was only paying like,
$4 and some cents, food stamps (chuckling)
for bananas, so when they
scan, through self-checkout.
So when they scan the
receipt, they see Huggies,
but it don't say Huggie
wipes, it just says Huggies.
Okay, that's the box of Huggies, okay.
And they just scan your receipt, yeah.
I learned how to get all
the expensive shit as,
what is it, 4011, banana
weight. (laughing)
Don't put that out there,
they're gonna stop it. (laughing)
Yeah, I hustled.
Boy, when I had my son,
I became a real hustler.
I sold everything then.
Ass, everything to take care of him.
He was my first love.
Oh yeah, when he was first born,
I had this overwhelming urge to smell him.
It was so weird.
'Cause I was a scheduled C-section.
So they brought him into me,
and they had him all wrapped up.
I said, "can you excuse me for a minute,"
told the nurse, she stepped out.
I unwrapped him, I said, "I don't know why
"I feel like doing this," but
I sniffed him. (chuckling)
Then I stopped, I said, "I
feel like a dog right now."
(laughing) But it was like
this overwhelming urge to
get his scent, I don't know, it was weird.
I had to smell him.
Smelled every part of his
little body and kissed it.
And I said, "hi, I'm your mommy.
"I'm the one that's been talking to you."
And he just looked at me.
That was really cool.
That's one of the things
that I'll always remember.
I'll never forget his scent.
I guess that's kinda normal.
Every species, that's what they relate
with their young, their scent.
I guess humans aren't
really that different.
'Cause it was weird, it was
just like this overwhelming
urge to sniff him.
Is that weird?
I think it's weird, kinda.
- No.
It's what we do.
- But when I think about
it, it's not weird.
Yeah, he was something special, dude.
And he was such a happy baby.
He kicked methadone for like, two weeks.
That was fucking hell. (sniffling)
I didn't know he was gonna
kick like that, he kicked bad.
I was only on 70 milligrams, too.
I started off on 110 'cause I had
such a bad habit on heroin.
And I forced myself,
brought myself down to 70,
and I still felt like shit,
but I didn't want him to have a hard kick.
Wasn't his fault.
That's why I don't understand my mother.
I don't understand how
she could take her kids,
how can you hate your child, dude?
I was in love with my baby.
That was the happiest part of
my life is when I had my son.
My daughter is different.
I mean, I love my daughter.
But I didn't wait for her.
I didn't put down the crack
pipe and the needle for her.
I did for my son, I wanted to hold him
more than I wanted to get high.
I wanted him in my life.
So I waited for him.
And I had to wait for
him damn near a year.
You know how long nine
months is to wait for a kid?
It's a fucking long time, dude.
But I was so excited about him.
My daughter, I found out I was pregnant,
a week later, I had her.
So there wasn't that
bond I have with my son.
It's different.
I could tell you, the beginning to end
with my childhood that,
I remember one time,
my mother beat my brother so bad.
I don't know why she hated us so much.
I think it's because my dad loved us.
(sniffling) And he paid
a lot of attention to us.
My brother was like, six years, no.
He was eight years old,
and she took this belt and
beat him from head to toe.
He had these welts that
came up off his body
that had split open, purple welts.
And I remember, I grabbed the belt
when she went to swing again.
I said, "don't touch him
again, don't hit him again
"with that belt."
And she looked at me,
but I was 10 already,
so I was about as big as her. (laughing)
So I was serious, and I'm used to
fighting out there in the streets
with the neighborhood
kids, so I didn't care.
I was seriously gonna beat her up
if she would've hit him again.
But I think she knew I was
serious because she didn't.
She said, "get out of my
face, you little bitch."
I was like, "don't touch
him," and I picked,
I grabbed him by his hand and
walked him to the bathroom.
And I was trying to put
peroxide on his little welts.
And I was like, "man,
why does she hate us?"
And then my dad, of course, came home,
went to help him with his pajamas,
and he screamed 'cause it was stuck,
his shirt was stuck to him.
Course, she got slapped.
He slapped her around.
I know, 'cause I went by
the register to listen.
(chuckling) You know how back home,
you had the registers
you could see through?
Yeah.
Me and my brother always
used to spy on my parents.
When they would go in there
with all their friends,
we knew they were getting
ready to shoot dope.
So we'd go in there and take a pencil
and push the register
open and be watching.
Be like, that's what
they be doing in there,
with the needle.
Kids are really smart.
I think back now, how smart we were.
We knew everything that
was going on with them.
We knew when they were all
out there boiling water,
and me and my brother would do this,
they're getting ready to (laughing)
And we would tell each
other and he would be like,
"yep, they're getting ready to do it,
"they're boiling water."
And sure enough, as soon as
the water started to boil,
they grabbed the pan, and all
of them file into the bedroom.
(laughing)
Yeah, kids are something else.
- [Interviewer] All right, Whisper.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting story.
- Okay.